[Applause]
tonight
in the show's 40 year history that
deserves
a round
i will never get over the emotions i
felt when lady o sent me these flowers
of congratulations
but i've got to do my job so for their
first ever live og chronicles
i had to ask how do you tell a friend
they've gone too
far with cosmetic procedures i would not
tell somebody who wasn't a friend
but somebody who is a friend i i would
definitely just say
hey can we ever talk you know i know
that other than that and i know you
started doing the
fillers and you thought of the face and
i have to tell you in the beginning i
thought it really
made you look brighter fresher fresher
but now
i'm honest you've gotten to the point
where your face looks
frozen and i like it better when you say
i'm concerned as opposed to honest
well that's not what you said to me the
time i was on tv
gail i was on tv once michelle and i had
too much cleavage apparently
and she said i got hit in my eye and i
said who hit you and she said
your boob did when i passed the tv there
was too much cleavage on tv
after 245 issues of o magazine with
oprah on the cover
it will now be publishing quarterly but
fans can sign up to be oprah insiders on
the brand new oprah daily website to
stay connected and be part of the next
og chronicles to get advice like how to
be boldly honest with a friend
about anything if anything honestly
comes from the point of view of love
the person can feel the energy of your
love come from the point of view of love
and that's what the person will feel